I'm Dan Perrault and this is how to
survive the sea according to the movies
step 1
don't f with sharks as the movies tell
us there's all sorts of sharks out there
like the great white shark the great
white shark the great white shark and
sharknado to fend off those pesky
fighters you might need a pole or a gun
but in the rare case that the shark
isn't chewing on an explosive oxygen
tank your best bet may be to swim even a
shark would tell you that you must keep
moving to survive yep
that's from a real movie step 2 watch
out for pirates there's all sorts of
pirates out there mustache pirates squid
face pirates and pirates who weren't too
creative with their costumes step it up
guys if they board your vessel remember
to keep calm and do what they say until
help arrives but whatever you do don't
buy a ticket to their movie or else
those pirates are gonna keep coming back
step 3 try your best not to get
shipwrecked there's a lot of mistakes
that can lead to shipwrecks like
crashing into icebergs pissing off
whales or speed to cruise control and
whether you're traveling by sea in a
boat or a car you never know when
disaster will strike but if you really
have to be out there on the rough waters
it might also be a good idea not to have
a Boston accent things never seem to
work out for those guys to avoid these
catastrophes
steer clear of storms and watch out for
the big waves step 4 stain your [ __ ]
light below where we're not doing
anymore so you got shipwrecked or maybe
even shipwreck don't panic help is on
the way
I just can't guarantee it'll get there
in time just remember to conserve your
rations utilize all your survival tools
and make love to a supermodel until the
Coast Guard gets there
not all these guidelines will work it
seems some people were just meant to die
in the ocean but if you have to go is
there any place more majestic to do it
than under the sea
and by the way illegal won't let us use
that song so well here's something
similar under the sea under the sea
under the sea under the sea look there's
a Kraken they're bad at acting under the
sea
on second thought I'll just stay on land
root safe